Do you have basically you have some criticisms of Quayman and
some of the stuff he said about Hassan and maybe Lonerbox even?
Yeah, there's quite a few. Let me I guess I'll just start with
one. We can work through other things.
um I guess I guess the the first one would be uh Hassan is a
a dradicalizing influence on youths particularly with his uh
influence on exposing them to the idea that uh the terrorism
is just a uh state. That's not what I said. This isn't what I
said. That's not what you said. No, I didn't say Assam was dradicalizing.
You did. You did say you you said that. Okay. I'm I'm possible
that the word dradicalizing wasn't No, actually. No, I think
you did say
dragizing. I I said I said some of these people could probably
deal with bit could probably do with being exposed some of these
ideas that probably be beneficial to them. Uh but I I said that
while Hassan's politics are radical, I think it's a limp radicalism
that has no impact. I don't think people are actually going out
and joining the Houthies or because of Assad's streams. I mean,
you particularly said it that it's positive that it will uh that
it will shake them from their belief in the State Department
designation of terrorism and make them I think it's positive
to have a wide range of beliefs including beliefs like Assange.
I didn't say Assan's beliefs are a particularly positive influence.
I feel like you're walking back on that cuz cuz Okay. Well, you
can show me a clip or you can quote me or something, but I I
didn't say dradicalizing and this is my argument. So, you can
either engage with this or All right. All right. So, well, we'll
I'll I'll take your word for that for now. We'll maybe look back
for that. So, okay. So, you said that uh repeat back what your
what your interpretation of what you said was. But it's good
to have a wide range of beliefs that are available to for people
to access especially views like leftist well not even leftist
views not especially leftist views but views like casans including
views like casans that I feel like the challenge what do you
think you in specific in specific towards you said something
about uh terrorism and the state department designation that
it should yeah I gave this as an examp I gave this as an example
so a lot of people just say like they they just see terrorist
as they don't They even really have a definition for it, like
a consistent moral definition for it. They're just using whatever
groups are assigned by the US State Department to be terrorist
groups. Um, and going based on that and like while that's reasonable
for like most political discussion, I think it breaks down if
you're actually making moral arguments about someone's beliefs
and most people don't have good good answers to that. So, I think
Hassan challenging those notions is is helpful. Okay. Okay. So
there so there was so there was a statement that was pretty similar
to what I said about it being him having a positive influence
by get uh shaking their belief uh in in just terrorism. Well,
this is like totally different to what you said though. But yeah,
you're just not in dradicalizing. So it's not that he dradicalizes
people. It's that I said this is one idea that Hassan presents
that is probably helpful. Yeah, exactly. Helpful to people for
people to engage with. I dradicalizing. It was pretty much a
match of of what I said at the second part half of it being a
positive.
So yeah, go ahead. Anyways, but based on that um why why um what
kind of positive benefit is there towards that? What kind of
groups that they pre people previously considered to be terrorist
groups are uh would be basically that I what what idea would
be gotten from that? Which terrorist group shouldn't uh be designated
as a terrorist group that Hassan's ideology would help someone?
Uh well, it's not it's not necessarily there's any specific group
that shouldn't be designated a terrorist organization. It's that
so there's a lot of asymmetry in the discussion. So any member
that gets in the conflict, people will immediately say, "Oh,
that well yeah absolutely whatever happened in that strike that
was actually justified." And they just sort of default to that
position of like, "Oh, well that's good." But as like an agriculture
minister and stuff like that, I think people would freak out
a little bit if say Israel's agriculture minister was killed.
I think just like not even necessarily taking any particular
conclusion away from that, but evaluating that that asymmetry
is helpful to your understanding of the situation. Yeah. So,
so just to be clear on that, even if a group is designated as
a terrorist group, um there's still the laws of armed conflict
which relate to Okay. You understand? That's I'm not saying this
is good for international. I'm saying for people's understanding
of these topics, this is helpful. Yeah. But for I don't I don't
think that I I think the idea you would get from Hassan is that
those groups just aren't terrorist groups at all and that they're
freedom fighters. So I don't think that has anything to do with
the I mean yeah if you if you take Hassan like 100% of the way.
Yeah, you might come away with the idea. It even says that on
his stream. So you might have to go further than that. You might
have to even find some other source that's telling you that.
But yeah, if you 100% buy into it, but we're not talking about
like I don't think everyone just 100% buys into the first piece
of content they watch. I'm talking about being presented these
ideas to engage with. Um, do you think between the two ideas
that of of understanding of just taking the uh state department's
word for it about terrorist groups or to believe that the majority
of those terrorist groups are actually freedom fighters that
are uh righteous in their actions, maybe not always doing perfect,
the resistance isn't perfect. Which one of those do you think
would be a worse view to have? Um I don't What do you mean by
worse? Like which one which one would cause you to uh to be uh
more more departed from reality or from like a more uh a just
moral position? It's like a way it's a value judgment. I think
it's a reality thing. Even in your opinion even in your opinion.
Sure. Uh well I would probably say yeah I'm like more of a lib
guy. So I'd probably say that you trusting the US State Department
probably yields slightly better results for my for my view, but
I think you should engage with both ideas. I don't think you
should take one as given. I think it's good to have both available.
I mean, I I would I would argue with it being uh that there's
that it's close at all, but that's uh splitting hairs at that
point. Okay. I think for for that point, I I've said what what
I can about uh the terrorism claim on on that being positive.
I guess uh the next uh question I have is um why do you say that
the Nagba and the exodus of people from the Middle East is a
uh is a unjust comparison but the that is worse than a comparison
to between Nazism and Zionism. So the reason I think that's worse
in tone is because you're com you're comparing two things that
are happening sort of within the same conflict involving similar
groups and I think it distorts the reality um of that of the
the actual historical events that took place especially the way
Ethan presented it cuz I'm not just saying it's not just about
like obviously maybe you could make a comparison in some way
there are ways those could be analogous and you could be drawing
on something that is analogous about about the two situations
totally possible um but it was about the specific way Ethan presented
it in in the content uke where he essentially said what was it
I I I'm paraphrasing this is going to be a kind of bad faith
paraphrase that cuz I can't remember the exact thing okay so
just bear with me on this one but it's something to the effect
of basically uh people talk about the Nakba but you know even
more were expelled from their homes around the same time it's
like well okay sure but that that's in many different countries
that's many different backgrounds of people uh being expelled
under different circumstances versus uh one group of people being
forced from their homes uh by a by a military. I don't think
that's like especially consider when you consider the time ranges
that we're using to measure the the numbers that he's using because
he says about a million
for it's it's it's a dishonest comparison I think. Okay. The
way he does it. Well, I'll go back to the comparison between
the Nakba and the Exodus. But I guess my first contention would
be with the idea that um that the Nakba and Exodus are are comparing
like uh direct problems like that have affected the conflict.
But uh
uh Nazism and Zionism comparisons are fine because they're not
related to the conflict, especially when you consider that uh
a huge uh I I don't um if if you feel like look I'm not I I don't
particularly strongly hold the position like it's not like a
whether it's worse to compare the Nakba to the Exodus or Gaza
right now to the Holocaust. Which one is a worse comparison?
I think it's get first of all it's not this isn't really a point
that I'm particularly invested in. I'm going to be real. I don't
really feel like I can't even I mean it's hard to be invested.
It's kind of a really stupid point. So I'd be surprised if you
were Okay. Yeah. It's a stupid point you're bringing up. Yes.
I I don't know why you would focus in on you said one comparison
others. Well, we're talking about different we're talking about
different like comparisons can be different based on context,
right? Not every analogy that uses the two situations is constructed
in the same way or is analog analogizing the same property, right?
So to say to come to me and say, "Oh, it's worse to compare these
two events than it is to compare these two events." It's like
I mean, sure, if you felt that way, I guess. Yeah. But this this
seems to be like a clear hypocrisies and both of like Assan would
always uh compare the Nazism to Zionism and you you really seem
to have almost no Yeah. I No. Do I have no problem with that?
I think it's I think it's dishonest. Yeah, I think I think it's
[__] I think it's dishonest. I think Assan's a propagandist.
I think all the criticisms of Sand I just don't think he's like
the worst person in the world. I just don't think he should be
okay. Okay. I'm not sure who's saying he should be at the moment,
but All right. Wow. Yeah. There's no humor to that. Wow. You're
you're a bright one. Okay. Yeah. But I I don't know. I think
that the amount of uh hatred and and uh criticism of Hassan is
pretty proportionate to the things that he says. Um No, I disagree.
Okay. So, hold on. Can I just I think it's like very I can give
you an easy comparison. Okay. Easy comparison right here. Okay.
Hassan said, "All right, he said
uh if you've had any positive sympathies towards Israel or Zionism,
I can't remember which word he said. Uh one of the two um in
the past or like in the past since the conflict or whatever,
if you've ever had it since the conflict, then you should never
be a dog catcher, which is like the idea of not being in government
because dog catcher is the lowest.
Yeah, you shouldn't even be a dog catcher, which is the lowest
form of or was the lowest form of elected position, which is
the point he's making. Okay, so Hassan said that, okay, that's
like, you know, that's that's edgy. That's kind of stupid. Sure,
I agree. Okay, Ethan Klein said, "If you think is dope, you should
have your family shot and burned in front of you." And he gets
no hate for that. Okay. No, he directly said that if you think
if you think that uh like are great then you should go uh like
you should you should go in front of he said what he said is
if you I will tell you I I listened just earlier he said almost
exactly this so if you think is dope maybe you should have your
family shot killed and burn in front of you uh maybe you should
go and serve yourself up to them that that's what he says he
says that so
just to just I think that's a pretty pretty inflammatory statement
that's probably worse than science to be honest cuz like there's
plenty of I don't I don't think someone should should have to
die for just having feelings about terrorism. It's America at
the end of the day. Well, I'm not in America, but I'm talking
about America. Light of the free. I don't think you should have
to be shocked and burned for that. I I just want to see if you're
able to engage with this at all. Why do you think he said that
statement? Try to do like a a good faith analysis of that statement.
He's saying that you should have to suffer the consequences of
things you advocate for. No, that that I mean that's like the
that's that's not like a good faith interpretation. I mean, you
could say that that's part of it, but what what is he really
trying to
I don't Okay, why don't you tell me what you want me to think
about this? So, he's what he's clearly trying to say is that
if you think they're okay, uh why not go to another terrorist
group and see what like what they'll do? Why not not have your
family go right in front of like of something he would consider
like exactly what I just said except with more emotional loading.
You just like complicated it more to emotionally load her. I
don't think that's exactly the way you're framing it. I said
that you should have to suffer the consequences of the things
you advocate for. That's what that's what he was saying. That's
the point you just made. Except you're like terrorist group.
I'm a terrorist group. My family, my innocent civilians. That's
it. Okay. Sure. Uh I I guess I guess uh so you said that the
Nakba and Exodus are a big uh false equivalency because of the
the fact that like what what would be your main contention on
why they're a huge false equivalency? Uh because the range that
Ethan selected for the Exodus was like something like what is
it's like 25 years or something. It's like 4 48 to 70 or something.
I I I think so. Right. It's like 71 maybe. I I think no I think
the range you use for the million is 71 or something. But um
so it's it's a way bigger range that time range than the NKBA.
uh the NUKBA was done by a specific military force that was driving
people from their homes, not uh a confluence of factors that
occurred in different countries over time. Uh this why I think
it's a force equivalence. Yeah. I mean one one would say that
Nakqua itself would have also uh like people fleeing from from
fear and uh like uh Benny Morris himself would say only 13.5%
of villages were uh directly expel expelled. So if if the I guess
if we want to say the timetable is what makes it uh is what makes
it a completely unfair comparison in a way. What is directly
expelled? Does directly expelled include the the fact that they
were like blaring noise and [__] trying to like drive
people from their homes like in advance and [__]
like what are we be like the ones that that are being expelled?
Fear fear would uh like fear and other stuff would not be part
of that 13. Obviously, it's much more the 13.5% that are attributed
to to like uh
basically being on their doorstep and being afraid that the IDF
is going to Sure. Yeah. Yeah. Like I I want to be serious about
that. That's obviously 13.5% is like is is is the that's like
actually forcefully expelled is what you're saying with 13.5%
like there was an order and they tell them get the out of the
village like right now, right? Yeah. So I mean I yeah I just
I don't think these are really comparable at least you can there's
probably things you can draw again not every just because things
are different doesn't mean they're always just analogous and
there are probably analogies you can make but the way Ethan presented
it was a force equivalency in my opinion I I think that I think
that there there was some sort of equivalency in the fact that
there was a similar amount of uh what's it called there was a
similar amount of fact of of like population movement due to
like the other thing Obviously a false equivalency here is that
um you know the Jews that were expelled from those countries
while that was obviously they did get a end up getting a home
in Israel whereas the Palestinians didn't get really [__]
all that's the other obviously. Yeah but that wouldn't be that
wouldn't be on Israel that part that would be on like the the
the neighboring countries that didn't want to take them. Um,
but that's that's what that I I would say that the I don't necessarily
I think that's a pure value judgment. That's not I think if you
drive people from their homes to secure your safety from another
invading force um I think you probably do have some shared responsibility
in making sure that's fixed. But if we're if we're saying what
why like why it's uh the difference I would say the the difference
um of like we're comparing where Israel allowed the people to
to come and uh join the Israel and their like the Jews from the
other countries to have a home in Israel where the Arab countries
treated them as as secondass citizens once they in the background.
Um, so like I would say that that's not necessarily something
that that could be used to say, "Hey, this is a a Zionist talking
point uh this analogous thing that you're trying to use for propaganda."
Like I I would assume that that your your reasoning for saying
they're disanalogous is that he's using it in a bad faith way.
Not that it's just like I I don't I don't know I don't even know
how aware Ethan is of his biases or like I don't I don't know
how intentional any of the disanalogous or poor points are. The
funny thing is one of the only things I probably agree with you
on is that it feels like uh Ethan is uh is hiding his power level.
Well, yeah, because I mean Okay, so you agree totally that it
is absolutely nonsensical for Ethan to behave the way he does
and call it a genocide, right? Well, and and call it a and think
of it as a genocide in the way that the
He doesn't It's not just like he thinks it's like a genocide
like white South Africans or weaguers. He thinks it's like a
genocide genocide or he claims to think it's a genocide genocide
like going crazy, right? I don't know if he described it in any
way different than he's described other conflicts because he
he seems to call everything a genocide. Seems to call Syria a
genocide. He seems to call uh
no but the thing is that he will see okay so in the Hassan debate
and I think even the Sam seed one he seeds every like point but
it's clear he doesn't actually mean to seed the point. He doesn't
actually believe in Syria is a genocide. Ethan says Syria is
a genocide. Yeah, obviously I don't think Syria is a genocide.
I don't think any of that is hold on. Do I have a clip of Why?
Why? What would be the rationale for calling it a genocide? Lots
of dead dead civilians. Lots of lots of dead people die. Yeah.
Big big death number. Big death number equal genocide.
I don't know this. Do you think that uh that that there's a genocide
going on in Gaza? I'm not sold on either side of that. I've never
been fully convinced by an argument. It's interesting. Okay.
I didn't I didn't think you would be uh yeah think you would
be it feels like there's like enough smoke for me to feel like
it might be um I don't understand international law or anything
like that well enough to make my own determination on it and
a lot of the time it does feel like people who argue it are virtue
signaling so I don't know how much trust some of the things they're
like pointing to as markers so I I just I'm totally undecided.
You think uh October 7th was a genocide? Um, probably not. Probably
not. Do you think it is more likely or less likely genocide than
Gaza? I I mean, this is kind of a pointless line of questioning
if you don't have a spot. I think I think less
uh yeah, I don't actually know. I I would because it comes down
to the intention and obviously you can point to like the stuff
like the founding chart from us and say, "Oh, they've got genocidal
intent." But I don't know like how much that mentality is carrying
over. I don't know what the purp like is the purpose of the attack
really just to destroy whole in part or was it just an attempt
to try and uh terrify the population and make them like maybe
try and coersse or some or how much of it was deliberately targeted
civilians and how much of it was an unstructured military I don't
understand any of these things fully so I I wouldn't that's fair
I would say that the majority for for in general uh I would I
would say that like the majority of people would would very quickly
say uh that's close enough to genocide for Gaza if they felt
like, oh, it wasn't 100%. If if the goal was just to terrorize
and and uh slaughter like civilians because they don't like Palestinians,
like they'd say, oh yeah, that that's close enough to genocide.
It smells like genocide. That's for sure a genocide. But with
October 7th, they'd be like, well, maybe they they also had wanted
to kill civilians, but maybe they also had a dual military. Yeah.
No, I'm I'm ambivalent on both of those really. I have not come
down strongly. Okay. Um Oh, okay. You said that that uh the definition
of Zionism needs to have some this might have been said in a
humorous way. Needs to have some sort of actually this No. Okay,
I know what you're going to say. You're going to point to expansionist,
but I absolutely use the wrong word. I shouldn't have said expansionist.
It's uh it's um it has some kind of like maybe ethnosentric is
what I'm looking for element to it.
Um it it can't just I don't think it can purely be like the people
who live in Israel right now should not be subject to some
um decision that forces them into a situation of total like it's
total unsafety, right? Like that's like the baseline I feel that's
the baseline take that most people come to it from is like the
people that are in this region right now whether they're Israeli
or Palestinian. I don't know if you're here by the way. You kind
of seem like you cut out. Is this guy here? Uh David, you here
buddy? David. Yeah, I know. I'm talking to myself. Oh, hold on.
He didn't send me a message or anything. Wait, did you expect
him to like cut in over you or
I don't know what's No, he he cut out and I started talking,
but I realized that it was probably cuz his mic cut out and he's
not here. He'll probably grab his phone in just a second if he
I'm guessing he like his internet cut or something. Was he just
arguing? I'll pick up from where he was arguing. Was he arguing
like um Oh, genocidal intent. And then he was bringing up no
he was bringing up uh the idea because I said Zionism should
have an expansionist element and I think expansionist is the
wrong word to use but I think it has to be ethnosentric. has
to principally believe that Israel should be maintained for the
Jews specifically as like a majority into perpetuity. Like that
is a core belief that is is a state, not just
that the Jewish state has to be maintained as like a ethnosentric.
But I do not believe that um at least Zionism Zionism is originally
formulated required Israel. I think they chose Israel eventually
and they Yes, I I agree. I agree that the the the at first I
understand that it makes sense to define Zionism that way when
it's in its inception that makes because there is not an Israel
but anyone being born now is going to come to a situation with
the baseline opinion of the best outcome should be found for
all the people in this region no one should be you know forced
out or displaced or any like that you know so to say it's like
a specific thing um to have that take as being like Zionism like
you believe in state of Israel. No, I don't I don't accept that
definition. I think that has to be not expansionist. Obviously,
that's that's the wrong word. That was a misspeak or stupid thing
to say, but is like ethnosentric. Like it has to be it's a principled
belief in the maintenance of an ethnic majority state uh in in
that region. Yeah, I I think I think that's kind of I I missed
mostly your answer. Obviously, I just got back, but uh I got
the end part. I think that's kind of uh a useless definition
considering like that like the idea that someone can uh can't
be just uh a Zionist until they believe that there is a a state
of a being in which there no longer needs to be a single state
for the people and there could be a shared state and that not
being a Zionist position is kind of insane. Every two stator
is a Zionist by that definition basically. Right. Correct. as
long as Yeah, that's that's
I don't think most two states consider themselves Zionists. I
don't think that's how people see the ideology, but how we use
that word, I don't think that's a useful way of defining it at
all. I I I think that all like almost all Jews would consider
themselves Zionists whether or not they're uh Okay. Well, I don't
define things just by how think of it. Well, how sorry the the
original like how the Zionists in general define it. Okay. I
yeah it benefits Zionists to try and convince lots of people
that I would
Can I just hear again your rational for saying two sters by definition
wouldn't be Zionists. Yeah, that sounds because what this I I
don't think that I understand that by the original definition
of Zionism which is establishing a state of Israel. I understand
the utility in labeling that as a specific ideology because you
believe in the construction of a new state. to simply say I don't
think this state should be immediately destroyed. That doesn't
see that's not a specific ideology to me. That's the baseline
position that most people have. So I don't see the utility in
labeling that as Zionist.
Meanwhist, what people actually see as Zionist is not two status.
It's people who believe in a principled state is like principally
believe in a state. I don't know. I I don't think so because
the majority of of like the majority of
Well, hold on. Let me let me just ask. Why would why would a
two-stater who believes that Israel should be ethnically Jewish
believes that Israel should exist at its current borders and
is fine with Palestinian Palestine being declared a nation with
its current borders? West Bank and Gaza with some like corridor
between. Why would that person not be a Zionist? What do you
mean by believes in a state? What What are you saying? Wants
that to be the case where there's a Palestine um there's a What
do you mean by wants that to be the case? Do they do do they
want that to be the case as in they think that it would have
bad outcomes if if they weren't allowed to control their population
at the moment or do they the ethnosentric part of it would be
important to them like that is really okay let me give the other
option that they should have that in perpetuity or that is a
core part of the nation that should be protected. Yes. I think
I think to me that feels which one? One or two? One or two? Wait,
so imperpetuity they should have like their their Okay, let me
lay out again. Don't interrupt me this time. Okay, J, I'm not
interrupting you. You said imperpetuity or is that a core part
of the belief? Those are the same thing. If it's core part of
the belief, you want it in perpetuity. Okay, J, I'm going to
lay this out you again. Please don't interrupt me this time.
Are you saying when you describe this Zionist or this two-stator,
are you saying that they believe in a majority right now because
they think there would be bad outcomes right now for the people
living there, but they're generally against ethnostates and they
would want that policy to be removed in a best case scenario
or they principally believe that Israel should be a state. Which
one of the two are you saying when you describe this two sayer?
Uh I think it would apply to the first one. The person who wants
it until there is no longer anything. Yeah, I don't think that's
I think that I think that's like a baseline outlook that's just
like you know. Yeah. So, so would you say that someone who wanted
who wants Israel uh who thinks that for the next 200 years there's
going to be no practical case in which the like two states uh
borders can be dissolved and there can be a one one state uh
paradise then thinks that it should until then it should be a
majority state for the safety of the population. You're saying
that that person is not would you would say they're not a Zionist.
That's not a Zionist belief that the state should be uh should
be maintained for the protection of the people in the region.
Um I mean it depend if they truly like there's a sort of a game
that's being played there. I feel like where if they truly believe
that no I don't think that's that person is Zionist. I I would
assume they also believe a similar thing for the Palestinians
that Palestinian safety might be threatened by uh one state right
now. Um, however, I think a lot of people that might say that
as a rationale actually principally believe in a Jewish state,
right? So, we're talking about someone's actual beliefs here.
And so, it's like, are you describing to be the talking point
they're using? Cuz I can understand why someone might say that's
a Zionist talking point. If especially if you phrase it like
that, specifically focusing on protecting lives from from these
Palestinians, if you put that sort of ination, I can understand
why someone would describe that as a Zionist talking point. But
I don't think fundamentally that belief is Zionist. No, I I think
that that that is a Zionist belief. And I believe that that is
uh I don't think that I don't think you had to believe in uh
that this land was promised to me 4,000 years ago or any of the
the meme stuff in order to be a Zionist. I think that that's
like such a narrow definition that fits so few Zionists that
it it's like it's useless and I I it just it seems quite mental
to to put the line there especially when no one I don't know
anyone else that believes that that's where the line is.
That's been my experience with talking people. This is I' I've
heard many people say they're two stators, but not Zionists.
I don't think every two state would be considered Zionist. I
think that's a very new belief. Uh that's like a very new
uh like post October 7th like radical belief that two saters
aren't Zionists. I Yeah, I I've I've heard political discussion
about this for several years. I never had the impression that
was what people were
revisionist only when I talk to you know people like you do I
get this definition so I don't people like like other Zionists
people like somebody who actively defines it as like the average
two-stator would not be a Zionist
I've never heard a two-stator described as a Zionist outside
just again I'll ask again um no I can't I can't name where somebody
has said there's a two-stator who believes in the state of Israel
and somebody would say that's not a Zionist Like would what are
you asking me for here? Well, because I'm positive that the whole
thing is on the backdrop of the Ethan Klein thing and Ethan Klein
is a two-state solution person, is he not? Yeah, but that's not
the only things he said, is it? There's more than that to why
they think he's a Zionist, right? Okay. Like, well, because he
goes on like these insane rants about Palestinians and how people
should be shocked and burned in front of like there there's a
little bit of reading between the lines. I don't think people
say you for David on that but I I have like a totally different
reading thean thing the Ethan thing with the okay well okay well
if you can find me can you find me okay here's an easy one find
me an example of maybe like Hassan or something saying that two
state are Zionists has that happened I have no idea I just it
literally is
and all the all the
toionism like that's all does think that Israel should be destroyed
today does think that fully no or is he like a twoan thinks Israel
should be destroyed today. Yes, he does think so. Well, he's
going to say yes cuz he thinks the one state, but I think Hassan's
just like an incurable.
I haven't seen say I I honestly don't know whether Hassan I literally
don't know if Hassan's made an explicit statement on one state
or two state. I haven't heard that from Han. So
Hassan is explicitly one state, one person, one vote. Now, he
also said that Israel's response I want to say within the last
to destroy their borders and to yeah that that was his his response
to Ethan when he asked the question what should Israel do after
October 7th. He said they should uh they should uh they should
free Palestine and uh remove their borders and uh remove the
wall.
So yeah, he would he would he would be uh anti-state.
Um, anyways. Okay, let's Is it Are you sure he's I'm 100% positive
he's specifically uh advocated for one state. Oh, yeah. Um, I
guess another thing that would uh be interesting is that you
think that the linking of to Zionism is
Why do you say that? Wait, the link of what to Zionism? Sorry,
I was reading Judaism to Zionism. Yeah, I think I think conflating
them is is dangerous.
But like because that because that that places the the burden
of the actions of like what you maybe call the Zionist project
on as a whole which I I think that's that's a dangerous game
to play. I mean why not why not just what do you mean? Because
I don't think that as a whole should be blamed for the actions
of Israel. I don't think they should be blamed for the actions
of Israel being Zion. That's what's going to happen if you conflate
the two. Right. There's going to be that totally don't support
Israel. like be completely they're going to be like you're complicit
right be treat you don't have to support the actions of Israel
be we already like I'm surely at least you agree with that you
just said they need to have sort of yeah well yeah I mean you
don't have to be no of course and like many Zionists would be
against the current actions of Israel Yep for sure yeah uh yeah
okay so as well as like I I I but you recognize that the conflation
the The point with the conflation being dangerous isn't that
are responsible for it. It's that if you put the burden of the
Zionist project on the the group of people that the ethnicity,
you are you're not only hitting people that that shouldn't be
hit, but also you create a dangerous situation where that there's
a there's a clear link between the actions of the state and and
the people and conflating those in discussion means that it's
going to it is inevitably going to be taken out on. Yeah. But
like we already we already know that that like when anti- Israel
stuff happens there's anyways a massive uptick in like uh hate
crimes like happened in October before Israel responded to October
maybe a major uptick in why does that happen why does it happen
to people if if it's Israel specifically because like most people
because people conflate Judaism because they conflate it's because
most happen to be Zionists and the idea
and they'll and then they'll say they're doing crimes against
so so you think that if people thought of Judaism and Zionism
as two completely totally separate things that everyone thought
that everyone thought of that as like yeah of course and Zionism
aren't necessarily linked
okay wait if if people thought that you think there would be
more hate crimes against Israel or something bad or less I think
that uh well this is a stupid hypothetical you're saying if zero
if they thought that there was zero connection between in Zionism
if they're just entertain the idea you zero but that's never
but then we have to yeah but can you engage with the hypothetical
but can you engage hypothetical I did I already did I already
said yes so you say yes it would be less it would be less obviously
so when I say the conflation of Judaism and Zionism as much as
we can say yeah obviously just try to convince people isn't necessarily
going to bring down the hate crime numbers my my point is that
get blamed for Israel's actions when you conflate the two because
that that is the fundamental conflation that violence, right?
I don't think that that's the reason. I think that that's already
a pre-baked thing that that is is always going to be the case
because there is some there is there is a link between Judaism
and Zionism. There is a a uh undeniable link. And the idea is
that people are going to instead uh posterize like the idea of
like anti-Zionist crimes and like oh no, I'm just doing an anti-ionist
attack against someone that just so happens to be the people
with the hats. Um, and then I think it is more dangerous. Do
you think there's a difference? Okay. Okay. Do you think there
is a difference between anti-Zionist attacks and anti-Jewish
attacks? Do you think anti-Zionist attacks that end up h like
targeting are usually just why why would they necessarily be
anti-Jewish attacks? Well, not necessarily, but in in principle,
mostly. So, you accept that there could be a difference there.
So, I mean, it seems like conflating these two like that we shouldn't
conflate these two because of how much of a link there is between
the two. And when anti-Zionist crimes rise, there just so happens
to also be a massive rise in anti-Jewish crimes. And there doesn't
really seem to be a a big uptick. You think it's good you think
it's you think it's uh good or smart or safe to conflate Muslims
with ISIS? No, because I don't think that there is a uh a You
think there's no link between Muslims and ISIS? No, I don't think
that most Muslims are linked with ISIS. You don't you don't think
you don't think there's a link between Muslims and ISIS? A link?
Do you think um people faced increased anti-Arab sentiment in
the US after 911? Yes. Asking you. Okay. Yeah. I'm just saying
that even though the group doesn't like basically trying to reinforce
the idea that the group doesn't represent
like it's important to separate those two things because when
you but I I think I think that there's control. What needs to
be done is there needs to be a separation, a separate link between
the actions of Israel and Jews, not not Zionism and because what's
going to end up happening is there's the the vast majority of
happen to be Zionists and be like uh they're going to say that
there like I think there's more of an issue. Well, it's just
a separate separation. Yeah, I I agree. You should separate just
someone that believes principally in the state of Israel with
someone that believes the Palestinian should be genocided or
some [__] You should separate those two beliefs,
but you should also separate you should also separate Zionism
and Judaism. You should separate those no uptick in crimes against
Christian Zionists. So what ends up happening is it just ends
up being disguised anti-semitism and anti-semitic crimes. So
that's why I'm not
very malleable to the the argument that if we just uh if we just
do a little bit more saying you two things can be true at once.
Two two things can be true at once. It can be bad to conflate
those two things and also bad to conflate these two things. Right.
I I think that I think that it's not helpful to you. No, you're
just like coveting over me making the point basically. Oh, okay.
No, I'm making violence. I don't I don't like it. I don't like
it. Stop. Yeah. What else is on the docket?
Uh oh. Okay. Actually, no. You said that Ethan Klein has gone
in on Zionist tirades. Or that's not exactly what you said, but
that was the the the vibe. We'll accept. We'll accept your negative
impression of of what I said, but I'm sure it was something similar.
But but I I'll say this. This is what my point is. He goes on
rants that can be perceived as Zionist very easily. Someone who
is left waning, pro Palestine, anti-ionist, whatever you want
to say, can look at the stuff Ethan says and go, "Dude, this
guy's like a crazy Zionist." Yeah, I can give you an example.
If you think is dope, your family's been shot killed and burned
in front of you. Uh here's another one. Um, do you know who uh
randomly in the middle of a debate, do you know the people into
their bomb shelters? That's another one. Yeah. Wait, what's what's
Zionist about that? Well, it just so it excuses
uh uh like the expansion of Israel uh by saying that they don't
care about their own people, so it doesn't matter what we do
to them. That is a huge extrapolation. Where did one get where
did we go from A to B there? Well, it came out of nowhere. So,
so my the only way I I can see people reading that is especially
if they're left leaning, well, sorry, not the only way I can
see him reading it. The only way I can see lefties reading that
is, oh, you think you're just like trying to make excuses for
this at this point because it's like such a it came out of nowhere.
First of all, he just like spurred out in the middle of a debate.
And then the other thing is it it's like an kind of irrelevant
point because they're literally taking the whole point in the
campaign right now is to like take out tunnels and the whole
point is to blow up on the ground. Oh, Matt Lt. Thank you for
the 10 gifted over on Twitch. Appreciate you, buddy. Thank you.
If if ended up instead using tunnels as like the reason that
that they're the tunnels are being targeted is because they're
military assets. If there instead were ended up being shelters
for civilians and was fighting out of the buildings, you'd be
seeing different different things blown up. I'm sure. Yeah. Adding
another hour to the stream for that one. Thank you very much.
There's a point to be made about using not having any civilian
uh infrastructure that's meant to protect civilians and instead
saying that uh and instead saying it's laughable that that uh
would use uh but any allow any civilians to go into this. This
is our this is our uh these are our fighting chambers. I forget
what the exact thing that was said but it was kind of unhinged.
It's an unhinged statement. Oh, I'm sure. Yeah. You have to go
see the terrorist group is unhinged. Okay. Okay. just had to
clarify. It's just like he spurted out in the middle of a debate.
It had like no relevance to anything. He just like blurted out
something that basically places the onus for for Palestinian
deaths on Palestine and not the people bombing them. Which for
sure there is some responsibility to go around. However, I understand
why someone that's pro Pali and left-leaning would look at him
just spell that out and go, well, what the is point you saying
that saying that other than to excuse what's going on. They have
no other relevance. Well, I think the relevance would be that
um that Hassan and other people are pro- Hamas and are willing
to call them
resistance. I must you understand that like that's not actually
really engaging with the argument about like as much as you want
to chill on it. There is like a kind of weird academic argument
being made about the nature of the relationship between the two
people and the oppressor oppress dynamic. And you I I don't like
this analysis either. But it doesn't actually address that analysis,
does it? It doesn't actually attempt to to fight that point.
It just sort of is just sort of you throwing [__]
out that kind of makes it sound bad. I mean, again, you you say
that the the the proper interpretation is that it's like a Z
uh the what the what what did I say that? Jesus, my brain is
is starting to shut off. But uh for Oh, it's the Vim thing. No,
I'm doing I'm doing the Vim. I'm doing the Vim, but I'm not leaving.
I'm not going to run. Staying. No, Muhar's a for doing that.
By the way, Muhar is literally the biggest in the world. He will
never face anyone that would could remotely challenge him. He
literally jumped on because he knew he's a big dog.
He knows literally nothing. And even uh most of the people watching
didn't realize just how little he knew about it. Uh well, I'm
sure Yeah, I don't think Vim's not. Vim is like an on how little
he knew or else he'd easily be able to challenge the things that
Mudar was saying. But I think Well, no, but he he wasn't failing
to challenge Mahar as far as I could tell. I only watched the
Muhar segment, mind you. I didn't actually watch the Hutch segment
cuz I can't be bothered to watch Hutch for [__] an
hour. But uh in the moot segment, Vim literally does and has
spoken at length about this have a sleep disorder where he wakes
up screaming after 5 minutes of having his eyes shut every night.
So I I when he's saying his his brain shutting off, I believe
him that he actually can't engage with the conversation at that
point. To be fair, he he couldn't engage with a conversation
from our one. It's Yeah. So I mean it might be that he is just
retired. But I I believe I do believe him at that point. He was
asking for a you know to just set up another date. If Mutah actually
had any spine he would just set up another date. He would say
yeah sure I'll fight you on full power but you know Goku and
Vegeta style. We'll come we'll come back full power but he didn't.
He's totally made. Yeah. I don't know if you watched the the
loner box segment though. Did you watch that part? No. Oh that
that was great. I don't I don't know if you any any of the lore
of Vadem, but Vadem has came to Lonerbox
uh several times trying to ask him uh about the history. And
for some reason, he he didn't quite get the message for like
a couple months thinking that Lonerbox had like a similar uh
prescription as him and was like slowly trying to get his help
on crafting a video. I might be this a little bit, so I don't
want to speak for it 100%. But then uh the general vibe was uh
I don't agree with what you're trying to say, little bro. I don't
know why you keep trying to point the the answer in this direction.
I don't think that's at all what happened at the at the beginning
of Zionism, etc., etc. And then uh there was a little a mini
crash out from Lonerbox after after he said uh Veem said it's
reasonable to think that Lonerbox is a paid uh Abarist as Hassan
said that it's a reasonable interpretation from Hassan. So I
think I mean it's a reasonable like uh thing to like you sorry
it's reasonable in that you could say that and be hyperbolic
about it and just say you're being hyperbolic. I don't know why
he'd say it's like well it's reasonable to say that if you're
making a positive claim you should have some evidence for it.
But yeah obviously the idea was he was trying to defend the claim
that it's reasonable that that's a uh a genuine belief. So I
don't even hear what Wait, what what claim did you mean? What
what claim? Uh apparently Hassan has said that Lerbox was a paid
Hasbro propagandist as barist. Yeah. And it's like I mean yeah
that that that's obviously I mean you can get what you're saying.
It's obviously bad faith but like you can get what you're saying
right? Like there's obviously hyperbole like it's literally the
same as saying like Hassan's a paid Russian chill because he
said Russia wasn't going to invade Ukraine. Like you've stated
an opinion that I disagree with so heavily that seems so to me
that it seems like you must be getting paid by the Kremlin. Well
I mean it's No, I don't even think it's saying that. It's saying
that like it could literally just be that you're doing it for
like I mean you could even defend it as like you're paying for
financial benefit. Like it's obviously like you're paid like
as in you're you're making money off of this by doing this thing,
right? I mean, you could probably defend it that way, too. But
yeah, but Vim was defending the position that that No, no, no.
Literally, it's it's a fair it's a fair position to believe that
that uh paid chill paid by Israel. Okay. Yeah. That I mean and
then he believed that there's a No, you would have to say that's
hyperbolic and trying to exaggerate to make a point, I think.
And then Vim asked if he uh was under the impression that he
would either not be allowed into Israel or possibly be uh be
murdered if he tried to enter Israel. So he kind of was schizoposting
on that as well. That was uh that was the vibe. I don't know
why I'm explaining the debate. It's kind of Is Arab? I don't.
No, he I don't think so. Probably some sort of Eastern European.
Yeah. Slavic of some sort. Couldn't really tell. Um I would say
on the Ethan talking about Oh, do you want to go David? No. Well,
you can ask the question, I guess. Well, I wasn't going to ask
a question. I was just going to say I'm pretty sure that the
Ethan point where he is talking about um your family getting
killed and burned or whatever, that is like a it's not even remotely
um like Zionist or something. It's literally just it's literally
taking the exact same lens. No, it's not it's not materially
Zionist. I I understand that it's not actually materially Zionist,
but I understand. Your argument is that from the point of view
of a they could go, "Oh, that that's not even the point of view
of from the point of view of someone just on the opposite side
who sees these statements over time, you know, is going to see
these clips again and again of Ethan Klein talking about terrorists,
terrorist sympathizers being shot and burned and about, you know,
bomb shelters or whatever. All these see these points and they
will have the same point of view. the same point of view. It's
totally fine to say most people think Hassan was calling for
that for uh what is his name? Florida guy, the health former
health insurance CEO. Uh Ron, not Ron, Rick Scott. He was calling
for Rick Scott death, right? Obvious. I think that that one was
pretty clear. He did Well, no, it's not. He literally wasn't.
But I would say by Quimman's definition here, the same sort of
reasonability. Yeah. No, I I would say yeah, absolutely. I would
say Hassan should understand why people on the opposite side
think he's calling for Rick Scott's death in that clip. Hassan
should absolutely understand that. Yeah. Wait, didn't he post
the gun or am I Is that a different person? Oh, that's a different
one. That's a different one. That was Tom
Cotton. To be killed. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. People don't realize
Tom Cotton's like Rick Scott. The Rick Scott one is um is if
Republicans actually cared about Medicaid fraud, dead Rick Scott.
That's That's all right. Never mind. I I I wouldn't make such
a strong uh statement about it really being a death threat if
I knew it was the Scott one versus the gun. Okay, gun one was
bad. That's why I was like, are you what is this cherability
here? Okay, so I guess uh one of the things you you So those
are your opinions on like the crazy uh Ethan like I'm being hyperbolic
Zionist tirades. Is is there something like stronger than that?
These are like really loosely connected. I think the knockbook
comparison those two um you know I can't think of like Ethan
Klein things that he said about Israel off the top of my head
but I I think when you it's there's like a so not it's not just
about the Zionist point right so we can because loan box and
even you would say Ethan Klein is a Zionist right he believes
in the existence of Israel so you don't actually whether he's
a Zionist or not is actually I would say isn't even a question
to you um but we can talk about like the idea that he supports
genoc on the side of backst. Um where I think there is like a
a manufacturing consent argument the lefties would make where
Ethan's entire show seems focused on um tearing down uh Palestine
activists for their upups or when they when they take it too
far with very little attention paid to the situation in Israel.
And the obvious outcome of that, the the material outcome of
that, if you believe the content and the views expressed in it
has has any effect, is that there are going to be more people
being Zionist or more people supporting the current state of
Israel or more people supporting the current war than there would
be if Ethan wasn't doing this or was focusing on on the problems
with Israel or pro-Israel content creators instead of pro Palestine.
And that's what he would be doing if he was actually if he actually
cared about any kind of genocide or whatever he talks about instead
of the personal grievances
based. I wish that was his intent. Uh but no, I mean like and
well no it's not about intent though, right? It's not about intent.
You're saying that Okay. So you're saying not not about like
that's not what he's necessarily trying to do. I think I think
Ethan is motivated on personal grievance. I think Ethan is it's
not about politics. It's not about the effect he's having. It
is personal grievance with the son's community. That's what's
motivating him. Um that's his intention is to withan with Assan's
orbiters. That's been the intention since day one. Uh I I mean
to to to be clear, if it were just that case, I don't think you
would also see a clear uh disconnect and a clear like uh fracturing
of the relationship under the circumstances of Russia, Ukraine
and and obviously this is less connected to him on a personal
level. And then the the what's it called? Tibet as well where
he's where he seems to be looking at his son in some sort of
weird way like this ain't this ain't this ain't a normal I I
don't I I'm not saying that he disagree that he doesn't hold
different political positions to Hassan some at some point he
believes that it's like like a a severe issue that's not okay
wait this isn't okay but this isn't like relevant to what I was
saying at all right okay my point is obviously from the perspective
of the lefties. The impact he's having, the outcome, not not
anything about intention, but he is spending his time tearing
down and attacking pro Palestine content creators when they go
too far, step out of line, have it on take, whatever. The effect
of that is sanitizing and positive for Israel in their view.
So for them to so it's reasonable for them to say from their
perspective, yeah, you're kind of like helping with this genocide
right now. You're doing positive coverage for Israel. That's
you're doing positive press. You're like you're like PR. I think
it's um I think it's unreasonable because what he's specifically
doing obviously is unrelated to the actual uh what Israel's responses
in and of itself. And do you think do you think um the political
reality in America has any impact on Israel?
Um yes. Who who ends up being president and whatn not is going
to severely impact. So do do you think effect on uh Gaza? Okay.
So, do do you think that uh media has an impact on the way people
in America think about about politics? Sure. Do you think that
Ethan has quite a sizable influence in media? Moderate influence.
Not not he gets like 50k viewers on his lives, right? Yeah. But
they're mostly girly girlies that are looking for drama. But
yeah, they're a bunch of Yeah, they're a bunch of Zionist girlies
now. Okay.
I've seen the subreddit. I've seen Yeah, exactly. But this is
the point, right? You you want this. You're a Zionist. You want
this? I do. You're kind of I would assume you're, you know, maybe
not, I don't know how pro Israel you are right now, but I assume
at least at the start of the war, you were pretty pro- Israel
and pro Israel securing it securing its interests and whatever.
Very, very pro Israel. Yeah, exactly. So, you're happy about
this? Why are you happy about this? Because it's positive PR
for Israel. That's what Ethan's been doing for the last 18 months.
Why are they unhappy about it? Well, because it's positive PR
for Israel. It's what Ethan's been doing for the last 18 months.
You you sure you get this, right? Um so to to some extent but
I think obviously that's a that that just is is what ends up
happening when I I think that that the the ways in which they're
becoming then you've just kind of seeded the whole I mean you're
just saying that you seeded the whole point like they can't justify
the belief is to become I I think that this is just a natural
effect of being disillusioned with the idea that is a uh like
resistance group that is just trying to do what's best for the
Palestinians and it
Hassan is you were arguing to me about Han how Hassan saying
his stuff is so terrible and dangerous earlier in the conversation.
So you you have to see the same influence for Ethan in the opposite
direction. Right. But I think I think that's what they're upset
about. That's what the lefties have a problem with. Oh, sure.
Sure. Sure. In their eyes. Yeah. Because they believe that Yeah.
I I think it's like totally reasonable for loss of uh of support
for is a huge anti-Palestinian thing as well. That's so I so
I think it's totally reasonable for lefties from their perspective
to brand Ethan as pro genocide. I think within their belief structure
that makes total sense. That's the effect he's having in their
view. Sure. But I I would just say that there that that person
would be just a deranged person in general. So but you think
that's the effect? Do you not think that this is having a positive
impact for the um obviously drop the genocide part cuz you don't
think it's a genocide, but but you do think that Ethan's content
is having a positive influence on people's perceptions of Israel's
efforts in Gaza. Uh no, I don't I don't think that's making them
meaningfully say that Israel's uh efforts in Gaza. I don't think
that people are going to be Do you think is meaningfully changing
people's opinions or view? You have to say no. Yeah. You can't
you can't hold the standard for one or the other here, dude.
Repeat. Do you think Hassan is meaningfully changing people's
views? Well, meaningfully changing it in what? No, no. If you
ask me more specifically, do you think do I think on the conflict
on the conflict?
Simple. You have to ask me about what what to be anti Do you
think Hassan is meaning do you think Hassan do you think Hassan
is meaningfully influencing people's perception his viewers perception
on the war war in Gaza?
Okay. So meaningfully changing is different than than having
a positive view. I think you I'm not sure if you said this, but
Okay. Okay. So do you think is Okay. So let me make this exactly
the same. We make this exactly the same for you. Do you think
Hassan is having a what do we say meaningful influence on his
audience in a negative direction of Israel's actions? So they're
having a worse view of Israel's actions as a result of Assan's
coverage. Sure. Actually, yeah, I I see where you're going with
this and and the answer is going to be yes to both now that I'm
understanding the question. So, yes. So, from a lefty's perspective
who believes there is a genocide, it is totally reasonable for
them to believe Ethan is backing a genocide, supporting a genocide.
You believe Hassan supports terrorists, right? Yeah, because
he actively says he does. Well, okay. Sure. The Houthies one
is is maybe but okay, imagine that Hassan who didn't say that
one thing about 10 toes down on the Houthies. Okay, imagine that
Hassan. Well, and Hezbollah and well, he didn't say support about
ever. He's never say sports and he said about the Hezbl that
he didn't necessarily have an issue with them. Okay. Okay. Doesn't
necessarily have an issue. Yeah. But that's not that's not explicit
support. Okay. That is the point. For real though, let's I understand.
I agree with you. I agree with you. But we drop the point I'm
making is that we're dropping explicit support one. Imagine a
Hassan without the explicit support. That That's the point I'm
making because Ethan doesn't explicitly support Israel's actions.
But you could make the argument from I don't even think he I
don't think he implicitly supports I actually think from from
their from their view absolutely he implicitly supports it. His
actions speak louder than his words so to speak. No wait wait
to be clear when I say that Israel's padding is parallel I think
he supports some sort of military action against Gaza after October
7th. I don't think yeah but we're not talking about but again
you're switching back to like his internal view when their argument
is based on effect. That's what I'm saying. What the words sort
of speak louder in actions. They're saying it back to genocide
spots genocide because that's the content he's producing is content
that that leans positive leads people to a positive impression
of Israel's current actions. I I think I think what we're doing
here is way way too like uh is is way too in the box. yes or
no. Turning things into uh into checker or
uh plus or minus a genocide genocide factor when it's like we
have to to actually look at what the arguments are trying to
argue and like I I think that the that there's too much of a
uh equivalence is being made between the uh direct okay if you
make every if you make every if you make every single argument
against it being a genocide but then at the end you say but it
is a genocide. Do you think you it's reasonable for people to
say, "Oh, I I think you actually either don't think it's a genocide,"
or it your impact that you're having through making these arguments
is making people think it's not having it's not a genocide. Um
I I think that maybe closer to the first one, I think that it
would be cool. Well, no, sorry. I wasn't even necessarily I said
or, but I didn't necessarily mean for you to pick between those
two. I mean like one of one of those options is like uh reasonable
like it's reasonable to come to either of those conclusions.
No, I think only the first would be reasonable. Um you think
it's only the first be reasonable if you make Okay. So if I say
if I say okay look this is uh I don't I don't this is going to
be like TLS or something. Um,
just if if uh if Billy says if I if I say if if No, cuz it doesn't
make it any better if I say Billy says Okay. But if if a hypothetical
person anyway says like Yeah. So, uh uh Jay's are sneaky and
they're subversive. They're destroying the they're a massive
threat to the West right now. Uh you know, I think things are
hopeless because the Jays just have too much power and they're
insane threat to the West and they're they're going to topple
us and Oh, no. But I I I don't think anything should be done
to them. I don't think anything anything should happen to Jim.
So, of course, but I think they're just like sneaky and they
control everything and like we've got no hope against them and
like they're more conniving than us and they look down on us.
They see us as they see us as boys. But I don't think anything
should should be done to them. This would this be reasonable
or would you look at this and say the effect you're having is
sowing anti-semitism, sowing violence against Jews? I think you
can guess I'm going to say these are meaningfully different.
Okay. Why are these meaningfully different? because well first
of all I don't I don't really fully understand your link I I
think or or issue my point my point is about if you make arguments
constantly in one direction but then you stop at the conclusion
that doesn't mean that your impact isn't leading people to that
conclusion yeah but his the conclusion that he's stopping at
is just not related to what he's like there there's no he's not
building up an argument on on why Israel should do a genocide
or should do that no he's he's sanitizing it by arguing it's
not a genocide Oh, sure. In terms of But I I think that that's
that's but I I don't think he's actually trying to test that
argument. And I think that the problem is a lot of people that
think genocide are not act are just saying a lot too many people
died. So he's and he's also of the belief genocide is too many
people died. So So he's he's sanitizing the argument that it's
not a actual real definition of a genocide that people aren't
even using in the first place. But uh but they're trying to get
them I guess I guess they are using it. they're using the moral
the moral weight of the of the genocide that's based on the definition
of extermination. So, so I guess in that way he is in the real
definition of genocide he is sanitizing the idea that it's not
that even if he's not saying that. Yeah. I just it feels like
basically you are a Zionist who supports a lot of Israel's actions.
Maybe you don't support the extremities of it, but this is the
sense I'm getting from you is you are proudly a Zionist who supports
many of Israel's actions more so than possibly the average person
and more so even maybe than than a lot of people in like uh uh
America even generally supportive of Israel. Maybe you're quite
quite far in the Z thing and you're you seem to be quite supportive
of Ethan Klein's campaign more than more than even Zobox. So
more than even Zyobox. Okay. Yeah. Um, so it seems to me there's
a reason for that and you you are like scolding the lefties for
pointing out the obvious reason why you're happy about Ethan
Klein's campaign. Well, even if I wasn't like even if I wasn't
as Zionist as I am, like I know a lot of people that are much
less so in the camp than I am. They're they're going to be like
ecstatic that someone's finally calling out like the the direct
threats to like people abroad. Yeah. They might even become more
pro- Israel because they're so ecstatic about it. Well, if anything,
they might they might be becoming more pro- Israel because of
their the rhetoric that Hassan is pushing out, like their their
dis disdain for the the way that Hassan has been uh or other
leftwing people have been talking so positively about those terrorist
groups. Okay. Um, that's what that's what I would say is that
just in general that I don't think you have to you have to be
someone that's ecstatic about Ethan's uh the positive [__]
I don't think you you you have to be, but I think there's an
obvious reason why you are. And you're you are saying that the
lefty shouldn't point out the reason why you're happy about Ethan
doing this, right? I I get what you're saying, but I I think
that that's just
like I I and I don't I I think that
like much better methods to do this. I think this this is a very
soft
um this is a very very soft movement in in the direction of like
being Zionist. All this is is really just getting people away
from like proterist views which I mean it's in general being
proter is going to being pro like Houthies and Hezbollah is going
to make you as far as you possibly could be from Zionism. So
shifting away from that is going to move you the by definition
is going to have to move you closer to Zionism just because like
the idea of those groups is to obliterate through uh I don't
know through violent means through genocide or through just cleansing
or through just like dissolvement of the state of of Israel.
So it's like that's the furthest you possibly could be from Zionism.
So any movement or anything against that is is going to by definition
make you more Zionist. So it's it's I mean that's just that's
just how that works. And I don't think there's a way to fight
against the those bad ideas without accidentally moving in that
direction. So I don't think that that that's a really like Well,
I think that there's definitely a I I disagree. I think there's
a way to walk the line, but I think Ethan has chosen to not even
attempt to walk the line. His entire content for the last year
and a half has been this. What What I mean, what what's like
some What does he need to walk the line back on? Um, well, I'm
saying you can sort of you can weave criticism of the extremities
of your own side with positive coverage in the direction you
claim to be advocating for, but Ethan has not done that. Ethan
has purely focused on the extremities of what he claims to be
his own side. Um, I mean, uh, he recently had I don't know what's
his name. Yeah, you were going to say that guy. I knew you were
gonna I knew you. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I I I at the end of
the day, that guy is super anti-Israel in principle, but like
who are we talking about? I didn't ask. He had on some there's
some guy that he's getting a bunch of for right now for having
on
Ahmed F
cuz he said what what is it they're all say? Apparently, I don't
know the truth, mate. I haven't looked into any of this. This
is like coming from Reddit posts are probably bad for other people
and all this. I've seen other video thumbnails. I've not looked
into any of it. But basically the gist of it is that he brought
this guy on who's like Palestinian but b runs defense for Israel
allegedly and has like a charity where the money goes to him
and the UN and doesn't go to Palestine but Ethan said it was
for Palestine. Um
yeah there's a whole bunch of complaints about that right now.
Well yeah there was three links. One of them was uh specifically
for uh a Gaza. another another if it was for one of his orgs
that is realigned for Palestine. I think I'm not sure 100% sure
and then Oh, it doesn't go to the UN apparently. It wasn't that
one. Yeah, but if it was UN, it was specifically the one the
like it was like this is specifically one that will go to Gaza
and not just uh any other like you cuz that was a broader UN
thing. Anyways, uh and then apparently there's I I don't know.
I think this is a bad empano thing that he uh what's it called
that he says he's from the the Atlantic Council which is a a
pro-Zionist think tank. I don't know I don't know anything about
the Atlantic Council or if he's on it or if it's a a proionist
think tank but that's like the the complaint. Yeah. Yeah. That's
Yeah. Anyways, you guys want an update on uh on Nicholas Deorio?
I don't I don't I don't even know what this is. I literally downloaded
a clip. I don't know what it is. It could be to kind of rolling
the dice here. I literally don't have any idea what it is. So,
I'm sure. Have you covered Glen Greenwald getting blacked? No,
but I mean that's probably Glen Greenwald got he got blacked.
There's videos of him getting blacked.
Uh, I mean, who's shocked? Anyone? Anyone shocked? Okay, who
got blacked? Wait, wait, wait. Wait, wait. Where's the video?
The the one of Glen Greenwald getting blacked. No, no, no, no,
no, no. Not that video. My video that's way better than that
one. It is actually so laggy. Hold on. There's only one clip
I could possibly want when I hear about Glenn Greenwald. I don't
know where it is. Hold on. It's here somewhere. I'll find it.
Don't worry. This one. Yes. Sorry. Me. I'm having a hard time
using the internet right now. Wait a second. We'll play this
clip and then I'm going to play the uh You're not on screen share
if you're meaning to be. Oh, I'm not on screen share. Well, you
guys don't want to miss this. D It's David's favorite guy. Got
him on the screen right now. No, my Instagram reels are literally
filled with him and just like uh a caption like I'm somehow I
think I'm I might be doing a similar amount of anti-semitism
spreading as on at the moment just through liking uh Nick Fuentes
memes on Instagram.
Glenn Greenwald passes by me. He's in the This is a gay club
by the way. Don't ask me why I'm there. This is a gay club cuz
Glenn Greenwald's here. Don't ask me why I'm there. I'm dirty.
I get it. Get it. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. Kidding.
Kidding. Kidding. Kidding. It's a joke. It's a joke. Okay. I
just need you guys to know that like again, not unlike his Stardust
comp comments from earlier, the evidence that Nick is gay is
the way